a warm welcome to tomorrow today and a
special very special show we're here at
the German Aerospace Center in Cologne
to be more specific at the astronaut
training center for the European Space
Agency and the reason that we're here is
because we have a very special guest
today someone who has done something
that many of us have dreamed of but few
have achieved I'd like to welcome
astronaut Alexander yes thanks for
joining us here on tomorrow today now
you went up to the ISS last year for six
months and became something of a media
star not least because you used social
media to explain to people down here on
earth both sort of the spectacular
aspects of spaceflight but also some of
the unspectacular things of what it
means to just live on the ISS the
mission was called blue dot it's that's
based on the the pale blue dot that was
a picture taken from the Voyager 1
billions of kilometers away wasn't
really a blue dot in your world it was
more of a more of a big blue ball do you
still dream about that big blue ball at
night actually you're right that we were
very close to that big blue ball close
enough that it pretty much covered half
of the horizon and of course leaves an
impression anyways if you see Earth from
the outside but I have to admit coming
back to earth was actually
disappointingly easy
I climbed out of that capsule and
everything was like it was before
and so so there was some letdown and it
felt like a dream that I had of being in
space now it's it's quite distant to me
so I rarely dream about being up there I
mean it's easier to come down than it is
to go up I mean maybe that's there's
sort of a philosophical lesson there
actually it's easier to go up and live
in space it's much easier on your body
when you come down it's quicker and
gravity helps you but as soon as you
have to walk you will realize that you
have not been used to gravity for six
months and it takes its toll even though
we now are in a position where
up there on Space Station we train a lot
so I actually gained muscle mass while I
was up in space it was one of the firm
kind of belonging to the first
generations of astronauts they come back
with more muscles than they go up with
which is really good and really helps
you when you climb out of that capsule
but nevertheless you have to you have to
relearn how to control your body how to
tell your arm to move up against that
weight of gravity because you're not
used to that anymore well let's let's
move away from the body quickly and
think of and talk a little bit about the
mind it it's it's such a different
perspective on the planet than any of us
have did it did it change your
perspective in life going up there and
coming back yeah that's exactly the
right way of putting it it did change my
perspective and since perspective is a
big part of every human being yeah I
have to say it changed me as a human
being seeing Earth from the outside
really changed my view on what our
planet is I mean I think everybody knows
that when you grow up here down on earth
you you don't spend much thought about
what this place is it's just there you
take it for granted it's huge it it
appears infinite the atmosphere is
infinite and all the resources on it
appeared to be never-ending now when you
see that from the outside that
drastically changes so you see that this
place is small like weather systems span
the quarter of a globe you you've
realized this is an place that's finite
it's it you can run out of things on
there like every resource that you have
on there you couldn't run out of it is
it fragile too I mean you always hear it
but this is this thing about fragility
it seems too fragile from space that's
what astronauts often say the atmosphere
when I saw it for the first time it was
a shocking feeling to see how thin it
actually is how what a slight fog that
is only on the surface of this huge
planet well let me let me go back it's
it's not a huge planet but on the
surface of this planet you have this
this slight fog only and that's all
there is and between us and the darkness
of space and you realize this is this is
fragile you can actually destroy it and
and even more so and this kind of gave
me a
of urgency and and also the urge of
sharing this is that we are able to
destroy this accidentally without
wanting it just by not taking care of it
we could go beyond the point of no
return on our ecosphere on our biosphere
without realizing it before it's too
late you just mentioned something you
said you know I'm a geophysicist you're
also a volcanologist were you a
scientist first and an astronaut later
did it come together which came first
astronaut or scientist yeah I don't
think there's a difference I was always
curious when I grew up I always wanted
to find out what earth is like how it
works earthquakes volcanoes storms the
solar systems dinosaurs for me that was
all one that was my surroundings how its
how it came to existence how it works
and that was the reason why I became a
scientist I I became a geophysicist not
because that was the only thing I ever
wanted to do but at some stage I had to
choose and so the choice fell to
geophysics at that time but it could
have been also biology physics chemistry
it was all interesting to me and now to
me being an astronaut is just a logical
consequence of going a step further and
not looking only at Earth from the
inside but also the surroundings of
Earth so I just feel like I can use this
to be more curious about what's around
us and and and put some more light in
that darkness so that's just a logical
path for me well light in the darkness
we're gonna be back with you in just a
moment but first quick impressions from
Alex and our guests time and space there
let's take a look at how much training
went into putting him up there
by the time astronauts get to stand on
these steps they've had to go through
some of the toughest training and
examinations they go through numerous
tests to prove they're physically and
mentally fitter than the rest alexander
gerst had to go up against 8400 other
candidates the training for his mission
on the International Space Station the
ISS took him around the world at NASA's
legendary Johnson Space Flight Center in
Houston Alexander gasps was shown around
the American modules of the station he
was also shown the technology that's
brought in there all astronauts need to
know how things work because when
something breaks in space they have to
fix it in Cologne Gast practice docking
Europe's automated Transfer Vehicle a
cargo spacecraft it was to be one of the
highlights of his mission during his
training for construction work on the
ISS at Russia's Star City home to a
military space training center Alexander
gasps felt as though he was already in
space he had to slip into an awkward
special suit and practice important hand
movements underwater in a massive tank
it took two and a half years to prepare
for his mission
I even trained for exceptional
circumstances and emergencies such as
fire because when astronauts set off on
a mission they have to be ready for
every eventuality
so Wow that looks like an incredible
amount of work that you had to go
through six thousand hours six thousand
hours I'm just curious what was hardest
what was the toughest aspect of the
training mentally tough was learning
Russian in three months was from scratch
so that was pretty tough did you did you
have you managed to retain it can you
still speak Russian yeah actually much
better than even at the end of those
three months that kind of just gave us a
kickstart but then I trained in Russia I
spent a year of my life pretty much
there if I add it all up and then of
course on the space station with our
Russian crewmates we talk in Russian
with the more Russian or more English
when you wrote I guess more English
because I worked on the European
Americans side but of course when you
fly up there in a Soyuz capsule the
Russian rocket and the Russian space
ship all the communication with ground
is in Russian so you have to know it
well yeah what just I mean in the crew
just briefly the political aspect of it
I mean all of these things happen here
on earth
all of these dramas difficulties
political problems do they get
transferred up into space too that's
very simple I mean you see that stuff
from space you can actually see war from
space I mean one day we looked out the
window and we saw dots moving and
exploding in little flashes and we
realized then only that we were over
Israel and Gaza and that people were
actually killing each other and we saw
that now if you see that from above it's
it's it's very simple because it's
grotesque you look at this and you you
realize hey yeah at some stage if there
would ever be life visiting us from
another part of the universe this is the
first thing that that they would see
like us killing each other us destroying
the Amazon forest which is also very
very visible from above mm-hmm how do we
explain to them what we do how would we
explain to them that we call ourselves
intelligent life but by destroying our
own
a home that we have so that is something
that you see from above and that you see
no matter where you're from one thing
that I realized is the transformation of
the the definition of your home region
in in Germany we call it high Mudd at
the beginning is kind of the region
where you grow up a little forests
around your hometown then you move
somewhere else you travel a lot suddenly
it's maybe your home country let's your
home and then in consequence of that the
same happens when you go to space when
you see your planet from the outside
suddenly your home is not that little
region anymore but after a while it
transforms you realize my home is that
planet so with your crewmates you're in
the same boat you're away leaving behind
you leave that behind your friends and
that's another thing I mean we know each
other since years before we fly together
right we spend time in the Russian
forest survival training at minus 20
Celsius without a tent without a
sleeping bag for several days that kind
of bonds you because you have to go
through that together and as a crew and
so yeah you leave that politics behind
your your friends your you get that
feeling of being from that planet it's a
feeling of us well that's a quick that's
another question I mean it's a you all
living together up there and very very
very close quarters you're seeing each
other all the time your rebreathing each
other's air it doesn't get any more
intimate tell me a little bit more about
about the day how do you how do you
manage to get through that daily process
living so close with other people do you
have certain regulations do you have
downtime
well you describe it as if it was a very
hard thing but actually if you think the
Space Station's as big as a Boeing 747
and the inside and there's six people
there so you have a lot of space
actually and it happens that half a day
you work in the module without seeing
the other so you actually miss talking
to a person so you actually looking
forward to seeing them at lunch and just
talking about the days how the day is
going and we all had the same humor that
was kind of luck I mean we couldn't plan
that ahead but we had really good times
of their just making jokes and going
through the day like that so it didn't
feel hard to be up there
you work hard of course you work like a
12 13 hour a day you do a lot of science
but it doesn't doesn't feel like you
have to push through every day no I
really enjoy being there well that I
mean that brings that's one of the big
issues I think when they talk about for
example the journey to Mars people you
know would have to be together and in
any ship going there for months and
months and months and the question of
what kind of what kind of of
psychological makeup should should
should happen with the crew I mean does
that all happen beforehand in your
training or if you were to take a
journey to Mars for example would you be
able to go with the people that you were
with on the ISS that was actually one of
the things that I told my two friends
before we departed after landing I said
if I ever need to choose somebody to fly
to Mars I would choose you to and that
is totally serious and you're right that
happens before you fly that happens in
training you need to kind of have the
right personality of course to to be
tolerant and so you can fly with anyone
but with certain people it's even better
to fly if you have the same sort of
humor the same sort of understanding of
life yeah I think that's an important
thing before you go to Mars you choose
your crew wisely and that will happen
and of course you you want to keep your
crew also busy you want to give them
something to do on the way there you can
do science that we need to do in space
anyways to keep our technology advancing
that's very important for us down here I
mean all the experiments that I did on
this basic and they're all there for
improving life down here on earth and
there's a very concrete examples of that
and you will also do that on on the way
to Mars of course yeah would you go on a
mission if you were selected for a
mission to Mars would you go yeah of
course you don't have to ask that
question to any astronaut they will
always say yes certainly mission to Mars
will be the next great adventure of our
time if you think about it these humans
are explorers since hundreds of
thousands of years we explore every
corner of our earth as soon as we
learned how to build ships we took them
and didn't only sail to the next island
we sailed over the horizon and now since
50 years
imagine that since fifty years we are
capable of doing spaceflight we're at
the beginning of this new period in this
new era in human history and we're about
to go on these adventures there's
nothing than a stop the Germans of doing
that are no horizons in space that's
right but there's a mental horizons if
you I mean we talked about the blue dot
perspective them the the perspective of
our Earth from the outside and how that
transforms as humans seeing that from
the outside so maybe the next boundary
the next mental horizon if you want to
say so it might be to go somewhere where
we don't see that blue dot with our
naked eyes anymore where our human eyes
look up in the sky and our home is gone
we can't figure it out where it is that
is gonna be a strange feeling and
something that we can probably learn
from because it even more so gives us an
understanding of who we are in space and
how significant we are for the universe
which is zero but it gives us an
understanding of how significant this
planet is for us which is everything
because it's our only home and we don't
have a plan B Aleksandr guess I'll be
back with you in just a moment
Mars of course would be a first stepping
stone on that journey speaking of ours
although no manned missions are
confirmed yet they're still going to be
plenty of unmanned missions going to our
planetary neighbor lots of different
space agencies are sending out probes
and satellites here's a look at what ISA
is doing
it's the next giant leap for mankind and
a dream for many astronauts Mars space
probes have shown a world of
breathtaking landscapes the surface is
dominated by a huge canyon system
featuring steep cliffs that can drop as
far as seven kilometers
Olympus Mons the highest mountain in the
solar system a volcano that's three
times higher than Mount Everest on earth
this capsule the Orion multi-purpose
crew vehicle could be just the ticket to
Mars for Europe's would-be Mars
travelers it represents an opportunity
to be part of NASA's future manned
missions to the Red Planet
the Europeans are building a core
component for the Orion spacecraft a
service module located behind the crew
capsule it propels the spacecraft and
provides the crew with water and oxygen
the newly developed transport system is
designed for missions who start close to
earth and go deeper into space
towards asteroids and Mars Europe hopes
to launch a space probe to Mars by 2016
the trace gas orbiter will investigate
the Mars atmosphere and deliver a lander
to the service to test whether a
controlled soft landing is possible
scientific instruments will then be sent
on a mission in 2019 to the Mars surface
a Russian research station and a rolling
laboratory from Europe the ExoMars
program as it's called will try to
identify threats and dangers that pose
problems for a manned mission will also
investigate the biological environment
of the Mars surface to look for evidence
of former or existing forms of life the
European Mars probe will drill 2 meters
into the ground
collect samples determine their
composition and see if they contain any
organic molecules
in Chile's Atacama Desert scientists and
engineers have practiced the mission
with this probe they've tested whether
it can find good drill sites and tested
its scientific instruments
it's hoped the Orion capsule with the
European service module will launch for
its first manned mission in 2022 the
astronauts will be the first people to
have traveled beyond Earth's
gravitational field since 1972
they'll probably aim to reach the moon
they'll remain in orbit for a few days
before returning to Earth one of the
astronauts could be the European
all important steps towards what will be
the event of the century in space a
manned mission to Mars
Aleksander guess what that you see is
the most exciting upcoming Eastern
mission well that's a tricky question
because there's lots of missions coming
up of course I'm interested not only in
human spaceflight but also as a
scientists of the upcoming exploration
missions also in the last year we had
one of the most exciting missions which
was Rosetta a spacecraft from Earth that
traveled for ten years for billions of
kilometers landing on a tiny little rock
out there in space and finding out for
the first time what a comet is made of
we did not know that before we just
found out about that so it's exciting
times we have missions coming up for
Mars and unmanned missions which you can
see as preparation missions for men
landings as well like this EXO Mars
program together with the Russian space
agency we will send two probes out there
in 2016 and 18 so that's interesting to
see and of course the main program o
visa we are together with NASA actually
building a spaceship the Orion capsule
which will carry humans out deeper into
space that we ever been of course first
towards the moon again this is a
stepping stone that we need to get
further out in space but even further
that spaceship is gonna be very capable
and I'm really happy and proud that ISA
is part of that what are the
technological limits though that are
imposed by space travel I mean oh we're
getting closer to overcoming them
there's the question of weightlessness
the body weightlessness radiation
there's all kinds of parameters that
have to be taken into account yeah
that's a very good point and that's why
it's one of the reasons why we have the
International Space Station because up
there we actually learn on how to live
in space for long like we're learning
about habitability modules how can we
like exchange or atmosphere renew our
atmosphere technologies for general life
support systems for a growing plants in
space you need new materials and and all
that that we we test that on the ISS and
I would say we're getting very close to
be able to fly out there as I said
before a
I'm one of the first generations of
astronauts who actually came home with a
stable bone density and and we actually
gained muscle mass on there which is a
first and that shows that we are
learning on how to live in space for
longer and right now we even have a
mission going that's up there for one
year so my colleague Scott Kelly and
Mikhail Kornienko they're trying out how
it is to live up there for a year and
see if that is feasible and I think we
can do it like from my own experience
coming back I felt I could have stayed
longer up there in space no problem
do you think that you have to be a
certain personality type to be an
astronaut is there is there a stable
personality type I mean I'm sure that
there's the selection process which we
heard about earlier is it goes on and on
and on is there a specific type of
person that's made to go out into space
well I wouldn't say I'm made to go out
in space but one thing you need to have
is kind of patience well let me go back
yeah I don't describe it myself as a
very patient person I would say one
thing you have is being determined that
you if you start a project you don't
want to drop it halfway through just
because it gets tough also you need to
be curious and of course yeah at some
stage a little bit ready to suffer in
training to get to your goal yeah and
then I think it does help if you're
reasonably stable if you if you can deal
with maybe disappointments which you
have on a mission like our spacewalk was
canceled communication I mean you have
to be able to talk to each other and
interact there in a way that's that's
that's that's going to be sort of
fruitful for everyone involved I mean
especially if you're living in that kind
an environment I know it is very
important not only to your crewmates but
also you have to communicate with the
ground centers with the scientists also
in training you have to communicate to
various people on different levels and
yeah I guess that's a very important
thing you know I I spoke to Thomas
writing a once your colleague and I made
the mistake of referring to him as a as
a former astronaut and he corrected me
and he said you know once you're an
astronaut you're always an astronaut
you're an astronaut forever it's been
going into space as an experience that
changes you fundamentally you never go
back you are from that moment on an
astronaut what do you think well I would
say in in the way everybody of us is an
astronaut our spaceship is just a little
bit bigger it's earth but if you see
that from the outside you realize that
this is just another spaceship with a
life support system that's bigger but
one that can break and it's our only
spaceship and we travel around the Sun
with it in that spaceship once a year so
it's something that we need to keep in
mind that we humans can be a passenger
on that spaceship or part of the crew
that's how I see a passenger or part of
the crew on Spaceship Earth yes you know
you're certainly a member of the crew
thanks very very much for being with us
together here on the show I like sundeck
yes that's all we have time for now but
of course we'll be back again for more
about the exciting world of science here
on the tiny blue dot check in again with
tomorrow today next week bye for now
you